and I would tell her I said you know
you're special and being special is
better and I want you to really be
something when you when you grow up
and I think she has
Cher's mother Georgia Holt has died she
was 96 years old my mom is fabulous the
singer shared the sad news on Twitter
over the weekend writing quote mom is
gone no further details have been
released at this time but we do know
Georgia was facing a series of health
issues back in September when Cher
tweeted her mom had been in and out of
the hospital with pneumonia
I love it when kids come up to me they
say are you somebody you know yeah
that's right somebody
who are you
Cher's mother oh
Georgia was an actress musician and
model born with the name Jackie Jean
Crouch her career began in the 1950s
starring in films including grounds for
marriage a life of her own watched the
birdie and lovely to look at but she
also appeared across the small screen
too on shows like I Love Lucy Lucy
there's one of the models from the show
oh yeah
[Laughter]
and the adventures of Ozzy and Harriet
well then go ahead and kiss her okay
come on just a second there
[Music]
Georgia dabbled in music too releasing
her only album hunky Tonk Woman in 2013
which she originally recorded in the 80s
[Music]
track means
[Music]
that same year Georgia was part of her
Superstar daughter's documentary their
mom love Cher my mom
was really
really
supportive
no matter what bad thing was happening
she would say trust me you're special it
chronicled her personal life and career
as she raised two daughters Cher and her
sister georgeanne
say that I'm a Survivor and I've
survived some pretty tough things too
but she is much braver and much stronger
than I am I think I gave her maybe the
start
foreign
[Music]